stuff
oh but we have another
special guest and student let's get his
opinion what he thinks
is the right move in this well after you
just said
this
a little louder
come on
[Laughter]
the opening
first of all welcome to the show maxine
vashilagrav after a great victory you
know plus two amazing situations for you
we'll get to it the implications in a
moment but this position before this
position this is move 20. let's go back
sam blitzed out the moves
here what were you thinking when you saw
him just chopping moves out move by move
by move g5
i wasn't sure about long castle
because it lost d5 i thought
maybe there was some other move for him
but
at the same time d5 is probably not the
end of the world yeah but uh it clearly
misunderestimated the consequences
all right let's get this position up on
them on your monitor yes yeah uh foreign
when he was playing that quickly were
you
concerned about his preparation
i mean i was looking at the position and
i mean my position is
still quite safe i mean she
already uh
yeah
i mean this was already
too deep i mean and uh in this position
clearly i'm i'm the one pushing for a
win but when we go back
he played this move knight g4 were you
impressed by that movie did you feel
something no an ig felt wrong
i thought you should play c6
i've actually gone to the confessional
to say that yes
right we did see you go in the
confessional so he did not play c6 he
went yeah i thought c5 was too passive
but c6 forced me easier to go
um something like
no i mean take knight takes i'm not sure
i'm better
uh
i thought maybe
after c6 something will work for me i
mean to
i mean not work so first of all i was
considering 94
sorry but there i thought you can even
take and play c5 now
and then he gets the d5 square for his
knight which makes a
a huge difference by the way breaking
news we should point out shakaria
without too much thought
did find queen to e5
these guys are good yeah that's a great
move
what an impression the queen makes on
that square and all the crazy lines with
bishop a6 we know are not going to work
well first starting with rook gg2 and
knight e4 bishop a6 b5 sick chess to go
from here but it looks like chakriar is
well on his way to winning this crazy
game
back to your analysis
uh so you follow c6 you play knight g4
you played rook to b3 yes sorrow
queenie one so i was not sure because i
have many options and here yeah as a
computer apparently says okay
which is a movie no other rock other
work to a3
also you prepared before and then you
cover the knight on f3 yeah so the other
rook
what
the other rook to a3 is the command you
get out of the way of uh the pawn coming
to b4 yeah and the point must be that
the we can like if knight f2 queen takes
g4 and i can
always um
go knight e5 probably already
also i'm not so sure about this position
pawn takes queen e2
and then or k3 maybe something like this
hard to say like for sure
one thing for sure is
he is a bit
for me a very exotic move
rook ba3 you know so look b5 yeah and
after knight f2 queen f2 g4 was
considering c5
and i decided against it because of b
takes c5
and if queen g2 gf
queen a5 and some sort of queen g4
and you know because you get queen g4
it's not so clear
i was considering also rochester instead
of quindito but it felt too
too subtle like ponte is on b frequent
g4 again
i don't see what i've achieved he gets
that nest on the d7 square yeah
so anyway
this you know
um
this was why i decided to go knight e5
and you know
uh pawn takes queen e2 would have been
much better for me because of c5 so he
went into this end game and i thought it
should be a draw but
uh
so knight f5 king d3
king d7 knight d2 i thought he should
break in d6 almost mandatory
94 k7 and i think this should be a draw
because in the game after knight g6
knight e4 king e7 i suspected that the
opponent game was winning it took me
some challenging calculation
and
yeah i could have made it easier on
myself after that so king takes i
thought was the most nice line
b3 king c5
kinky [ __ ] b4
and here i think the best move is king
f5
b3 c5 a4
d6
cd
cb
a3 b7
a2 a8
a1
queen d6
queen from check
and no king e5 you cannot take any of
the pawns yet um
king takes even take c5
and you can't touch the
queen e6 mighty king e6 might even win
yeah but that's
very exotic
yeah that's very exotic but it might win
as well
i thought king e5 queenie took a five
queen
deep calculation we're seeing a lot of
deep calculations so far in only three
rounds of this tournament yeah maybe
king g6 is more precise let's say
let's set our [ __ ] e6 this is nice
impressive
calculation
or queen b5 both pawns are going to stay
on the board
because of this check and that's going
to be all she wrote yeah
so and after pawn takes king foy just uh
this nice look song after king f6 b3 h5
g3 alright we looked at that during our
analysis
as well and so
some told me after the game that i
missed an easier
way to finish the game
so which is true king g6 c5 dc
d6 king f7 and just king e5
just king e5 yeah
king
k8 king e6
king d87 and you know you
you push one pawn i will push the other
opponent
i'm just waiting
no i think we were considering after
king takes e5 not king e8
um
we were just going to push a pawn
so c4 yeah
yes
because
oh bc a4
king d5 so
yeah king g5 must be winning ace
freaking c6
nice that'll do it hello very very very
nice
but then i managed to
yeah settle myself in this queen end
game and win it convincingly there's a
lot of explosive games happening and big
scores being run up what do you think is
the cause of that
people are coming in shape
people
not just me but
my fellow competitors worked a lot for
the world cup i think and you know i
mean sometimes it doesn't change the
result you have
in such random tournaments i mean when
it's not i never considered what got
random but let's say things
on a bad day things can happen but you
know i mean hard work pays off
you are tied for first with fabi and
wesley yeah that's right uh so certainly
a big chase chakriar looks like he's
going to win this game as well it's all
about this this grand chess tour
chase did you think you had a chance
after the rapid and blitz
um
[Music]
well i certainly didn't think i had a
chance after bucharest but
you know i'm just gonna play my
the best chess i can possibly show in
this tournament and
then we'll see like i'm
already quite happy with
how i played i mean even more than the
outcome of the games which is great i'm
generally quite happy with
the play i showed so far so let's hope i
can
keep on doing that all right we look
forward to seeing you play good luck
tomorrow thank you maurice
congratulations maxine very
very impressive calculation